(beeping)
(woman on PA)
Last stop in Manhattan.
The train will now be going
express to 37th Street.
Sorry.
Oh.
All right.
(beeping)
♪
Uh, hello...
Garol.
I'm not sure if I'm in
the right place--
You are.
Okay.
I'll just hand that--
All right.
Oh, Jesus.
Thank you so much.
It took me so long--
ID.
Jeremy Santos.
No, I'm not a man.
Jeremy's actually my--
he's my husband.
So.
We both work so much.
You know how it is.
But when we're home,
we're home and we--
I need his ID or he can
come down here
with two pieces of
mail with his name on it.
Gar... ol, you seem like,
so great.
I can just tell
from this interaction.
Can you just like, look
the other way this time?
I'm sorry, I can't.
My supervisor's watching.